on a été un peu sous le choc d'autant
plus que c'est samedi c'est c'est le
jour du Shabbat où on n' pas de
connexion au médias direct et le
lendemain dimanche était jour de fête
qui conclut les dernières fêtes euh fête
très joyeuse la conclusion de la Torah
et cetera vra information c'est-à-dire
on a pu réellement s'informer de tout ce
qui était a été qui hier soir lors de la
la
faite nous avons évidemment des euh des
des personnes en Israël que nous
connaissons et des associations avec qui
nous sommes en contact et donc
évidemment ils nous ont envoyé leur
demande et leurs besoins et nous sommes
déjà en train de mettre une collecte en
route pour pouvoir les aider voir
qu'est-ce qui est nécessaire comment
faire surtout pour les aider et bien sûr
avec toute la solidarité la solidarité
que nous avons avec les communautés d'
Israël
[Musique]
sur Montini pour l'instant il n'y a pas
de crainte et depuis que nous sommes
installés ici tout s toujours bien passé
néanmoins bien sûr sont des choses
puisque on ne sait pas qu'est-ce qu'il
peut avoir dans les dans les têtes des
uns et des autres malheureusement
et évidemment il faut que que tout reste
dans l'ordre donc une inquiétude je peux
pas dire qu'il n'y en a pas mais en même
temps il continuer notre vie normale
évidemment les enfants continueront à
aller dans les écoles ça il n'y a pas de
[Musique]
souci